um and i'll start off the meeting
so welcome to today's licensing
subcommittee my name is james matson and
i'm acting as the meeting facilitator to
conduct the election of chair for this
meeting
so can i have a nomination for charities
i'd like to nominate councillor linda
rogers please
receiver and are you improvement without
counseling rogers
yes thank you okay then um so
good elected chair for this licensing
subcommittee i'll hand over to you thank
you very much
thank you welcome everyone to today's
meeting of the licensing subcommittee
prior to this meeting all participants
have previously checked that they can be
heard and seen
and can see and hear other members to
double check this and to introduce
everyone who is present at this remote
meeting
i would kindly ask that when i that
could you confirm your attendance and
your role with job title when i say your
name
thank you um i have counsellora but
she is not attending and councillor wing
councillor wing central harbour round
rumsgate
miss phillips litigation solicitor
i'm good morning i'm jennifer phillips
the principal litigation lawyer
for thenet council thank you mr clapson
yeah james clapton democratic services
miss lane yeah i'm katy laney
thank you mr brown
is mr brown here no he's on the next one
okay thank you uh miss brock
uh alison technical support manager
thank you mr
no mr hayden i know he's here
yep steve hayden i'm the owner of the
waves thank you
uh i'm mr kramer yes good morning uh
hans grimer here
i live next door to the waves thank you
have i missed anyone present here today
no if you have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
katie the democratic services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
she will put her phone number in the
chat function
i would ask participants when you're not
speaking to please
mutual microphone this minimizes
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on what has
been granted permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to
silence
and they're not used to make or receive
calls whilst at the meeting in
meetings in progress do not turn off
your phones in case you need to be
contacted in the event of technical
difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
except for the private deliberation part
of this meeting
a separate private hangout meeting will
take place for this element of item
4 and the public meeting will resume in
its previous digital
location 30 minutes later unless there
is reason to suggest
an earlier or later time no unauthorized
recordings of the confidential item of
business
is permitted to take place are there any
apologies for absence
counselor i presume um not i'm aware of
chair thank you uh are there any
declarations of interest
no uh agenda item three
application to various premises license
the waves bnb
i call upon ms phillips the council's
principal litigation solicitor
to explain to the parties the procedure
that we will be taking during this
hearing
good morning thank you very much i'd
like everyone present to know that the
decisions made
by this subcommittee are made in
accordance with the license in acts
2003 and based on the information
presented in this agenda together with
any
verbal submissions made today decisions
of the subcommittee are not politically
based this subcommittee must act
impartially
and offer a fair and unbiased hearing of
today's application
the subcommittee will give a fair
consideration to
everything it hears and reads today we
are here to consider the application for
a variation of the premises license at
the waves bnb
under section 17 of the license inactive
2003.
the applicant has applied to vary the
license at the waves bnb
um at the address aforementioned the
variation is to include
the first floor area and balcony as
marked on the plan as part of the
license area of the premises
the bar on the ground floor has already
been moved under a minor variation
application
as this did not alter any of the
licensing objectives or
increase any of the licensing activities
we will hear the parties in the
following
order the licensing officer the
applicant for the variation of the
license
and any representations each party has
up to 15 minutes to make pres its
presentation
and this includes any witness called you
may not be allowed to introduce any new
evidence at this stage
that has not been disclosed in the
proceedings
and you may be um art to cease from
including any new evidence you are not
expected nor required to talk for that
period for the full 15 minutes
following each presentation the members
of the committee may ask you
questions and may out
your witness questions there are no time
limits
for the members questions at the end of
the proceedings
each party will have five minutes to
make a closing statement in the
following order
the applicant for the license and any
representatives
please note to ensure that this virtual
meeting runs smoothly
only one individual shall be allowed to
speak at a time
any person speaking must be permitted to
finish
what they are saying without
interruption the meeting will then
adjourn
for the subcommittee to consider its
decision
when we adjourn the subcommittee members
myself as the legal officer
will leave this virtual meeting and if
you'd like to hear
the decision of the subcommittee i shall
advise everyone
of the decision approximately 30 minutes
from the time of the adjournment
and you can either remain in a virtual
meeting during this time
or you can use the link again to
re-access the meeting
if you do decide to wait in the virtual
meeting room
please turn off your cameras and
microphones to ensure your privacy
as the recording will continue thank you
sorry somebody's got a bit of feedback
there
um i would like to stress the importance
following the hearing procedure
and that there will be an opportunity
for all parties to make a final
presentation after questioning therefore
i would advise all present
to please follow the procedure and to
respect those speaking by not
interrupting or speaking over others
if people do interrupt or speak over
others
i as chairman will ask them to refrain
from doing so
if they continue to do so after my
warning then
that individual could face being asked
to leave the meeting
could the licensing officer please
present the report
good morning everyone uh mr hayden has
applied
to vary his uh current license to
include part of the first floor area and
the balcony as part of the licensed
premises
on advertising this we've received one
representation
which is attached to an nx2 and the
environmental health department have
agreed conditions with the applicant
which would be non-use of the balcony
area
after nine o'clock and mr hayden has
also agreed to put up acoustic screens
on that area should his application be
approved
so the uh the conditions from the
environmental health department are also
attached at annex 3.
that's it thank you
thank you would the applicant present
their application please
good morning um yes my application is to
be able to use my dying dining area
upstairs and
um the balcony area um this is
because of a simple sum with the kovid
19 restrictions
and trying to create enough space to be
able to use the indoors
if the government lift the thing on the
17th
we just want to be able to give a safer
area
to stay i'm happy as i've discussed with
katie
laying the environmental protection to
only use the outdoor area until nine
o'clock
um which we can use and we i believe
we're entitled to use for the
breakfast guests um but we're not
entitled to use it for the public at the
moment so i just want to be able to use
it for the public i want to give them
something that they can
sit out the front look at the sea um the
minutes next door are able to use theirs
so um yeah i just we've spent quite an
extensive amount of money converting it
all over we've given up more of our
family home
to be able to do this because it's a
simple sum that we need to be able to
put bums on seats to survive
we've had a year now with no money um
and this
will turn the waves into something that
is
usable if you like in the current
climate
thank you thank you does the licensing
officer have any questions for the
applicant
no thank you chair thank you um
do the police have any questions we
don't have the police here do we
no they didn't put any objections
forward thank you
do the environmental protection officers
have any questions for the applicant
no thank you thank you does the member
of the public have any questions for the
applicant
no do members of the committee have any
questions for the applicant
yes please chair uh yes councillor
uh i think i've got three so presently i
think you've answered one of my
questions the balcony is used for
bed and breakfast uh customers only
and it will move to the general public
being able to to use that
you also mentioned that it's to do with
the covid situation so is this is a
temporary thing so that what if we
eventually move to a situation where we
don't have to social distance
will you then revert back to how you've
operated
i guess um i'd like to keep it
obviously it's an expansion of business
that's been closed and every year
i think um if we can keep it
it will make the waves a better place
give you know offering the balcony
upstairs i can't get a great deal of
people up there
probably 20 if that in the coping
situation
maybe 12. um
but it does give us a better opportunity
to be able to do something now
um and then better the place for the
future it you know it's a great
balcony it's not huge but it does
overlook the sea
and overlooks the gardens
a number of uh houses quite close i'm
not familiar
i cycled most of the coast regularly but
i don't particularly look behind
so i think there was one house the top
side of of
the property and then three behind
what's what's the sort of
distance between where you are and and
the houses
in terms of meters i i guess or feet
okay so on one side we've got the minus
bar and brasserie
and the bike hire and honey's calf okay
on the other side is hengist road which
is our private road we are living
hands is at the back of my property
which
is probably
40 meters away okay opposite
us we have um henges road which is barry
and um jackie and it goes up through
number one three
five um i believe they've um
i've spoken to them all and they don't
have any problems at all i've agreed
with barry who is the closest um
resident in angus road with me
that we would put an acoustic fence up
on his side as well
and he actually said well you know you
don't need to steve that
it doesn't bother us we've had people up
here as when we had it as a personal
family home
um we've had you know 20 friends up here
with a barbecue
and it doesn't seem to create any um
discomfort
for barry who is direct opposite us
so i'm assuming that the people that are
drinking on the balcony will be seated
they'll be in seated seated areas
yes they will okay okay thank you
thank you
thank you do the
environmental protection officers have
any questions for the applicant
no thank you thank you
so i'm trying to get to skip past the
police bit
um with the environmental protection
officers please present their case
yes good morning um i have actually
agreed conditions
um as miss brock said with mr hayden
the external area of the property did
cause me some concerns about late-night
noise to residents that are nearby
particularly the two nearest which do
have line of sight
from the balcony area to the neighboring
properties
on the site visit and discussion with mr
hayden subsequently we agreed
um that nine o'clock would be
appropriate to shut that
area so that everybody had to then come
into the property
after nine pm and as mr hayden said he
has agreed to put some accru
acoustic screening um on the south and
east border which
um is the line of sight between the
neighboring properties
so we agreed those conditions thank you
does the applicant have any questions
for the environmental protection officer
no thank you thank you okay
uh does the member of the public have
any questions for the environmental
protection officer
no thank you do members of the committee
any questions for the environmental
protection officer
yes please chair what would the acoustic
carriers look like
um will they detract from the
the look of the place i i wouldn't know
what they look like
yes um they would have to um
put those in through the planning
planning um
application and they would be agreed um
there's
various various ones sometimes they can
be glass sometimes they can be
uh you know a wood um
so it depends on on what mr hayden
sources
okay so i'm am i assuming that even if
we approve this license that he couldn't
go ahead until the application for the
for the uh acoustic barriers was
approved via planning
yeah the planning is a is a separate um
and he does um mr hayden does have to
apply for
planning permission for the extension of
hours as well
okay okay thank you thank you
this is the point of the meeting at
which members of the public get to make
their representations
mr kramer please can you make your
representation
sure yes thank you um first of all i
have no issue with this application
if it was for what was stated to call
with 19
relief i have absolutely no issue with
that if this was a temporary thing
as as it was presented early on uh
let's say until the use to the end of
june or something i understand and
that we had no issue with that however
we've just learned that that is not
necessarily the case that we want to
continue using it going forward um
so if that is the case if you want to
continue using it it's basically an
expansion of the
the the premises of the use of it right
so so from our perspective um
initially this was it was a family home
next door um it got bmb
rooms um anyway it got extended to a
hotel with guests the the
the guests could use the bar it then we
got retrospective applications so
for it to be used as a cafe and a bar
the
green in front of it's been used now
with uh
i think 10 or 11 benches as well for
seating
there's a ground floor extension so the
building keeps expanding and
the result of it is now that i live next
to walk to a a pub
basically a bar restaurant cafe or
whatever you want to call it this is in
in a residential road
so what i'm trying to convey to you here
is that if
you give a license to this that
basically means that any house that
that's house or any substantial house
next to another dwelling
can be turned into a pub or or a bar and
i find that boring
as it is right now um the permission for
the property is only to be used until
nine o'clock anyway the planning
commission but there is no
um planning application that allows the
usage the opening hours to go beyond
that
however over the last well not the last
year but before that
it was open until 11 o'clock at night
and and and actually you know
that in itself is fine so the variation
in the hours
i don't have a huge issue with as long
as you know we close it by by
9 o'clock outside and there was no music
no alcohol taken off of sight
very similar to uh to the cafe
for vct honeys that that's no issue of
for us
at all right so we have however
suffered quite a bit with with noise in
the past
based as well and certainly older has
been a huge issue for us in the in the
past
and that's only been when the waves has
been opened so
now opening uh upstairs would bring it
closer to us
of course internally so i have some
concerns around sound there
sound insulation so that would have to
be be investigated
um you know there are windows in there
so so we would be concerned about that
when the application was originally
approved
the statement was it is far away from
from us as possible and
and that is true obviously it brings it
brings it closer now
but particularly the balcony that would
be our concern and i understand the
comments we've made around sound
barriers
i'm not sure how effective they will be
given that it's the first floor
and how that sound will bounce off the
other buildings around us
um it's just our experience in the past
with that
i must say that the balcony so far has
not been used by guests of the bmd i've
not
witnessed that at all there's no seating
up there that i've
seen been used but again that would have
been only a few people
so that's not a huge issue right if
there's a few people up there
there is no way we could guarantee that
people would be seated
as was maintained you know if you always
see people will stand up
right and it's not only on the on the
south and the
and the east side some will also go go
around around the other side but
for me the main thing around all of this
this is a further expansion of
of the business on this plot right next
door to our house
um you can check with the bitcoin with
the tdc
and maybe you have we have in the past
uh
had a few incidents that we have locked
and that have been investigated
by tdc around odor and
and waste and sound complaints that we
had
this is not a pleasure for me i must say
i really don't like doing this
um i would much rather that that that
you know
we just live next to it in all
peace and everything right so i would
say it is closer than 40 meter i'm just
looking out out the window here it is
closer than 40 meters i would say it's
probably around
25 but but give that what it is
now i would say can we find a compromise
and and of course there are ways
we can we can look at this and we should
probably go down that road right
so with regards to the hours which is
which is one request
i think like we're the you've done with
with vct honeys
that's fine right make make a provision
that uh
11 o'clock indoors you know nine o'clock
outdoors and making sure there is no
sound or no alcohol taken off side and
then that's absolutely fine
from my perspective at least using the
first floor well
internally well as long as there is no
sound issues
again i can't i can hardly object
against that right that's inside
although it is an expansion of of the
business of course
the balcony though for me is a huge
issue so
i i hope that you can look at that and
um you know the building can there
they're already
vented outside this is quite substantial
already given that it's in the is a
residential road so i i really think
it's it's unnecessary
for us to do that so that's what i
wanted to uh
to bring to you so so thank you for
listening to me
thank you thank you does the applicant
have any questions
no thank you
do the environmental protection officers
have any questions for the applicant
no thank you do members of the committee
have any questions
thank you chair thank you um
i would now like to ask each party to
sum up and make final representations
would the environmental protection
officers like to sum up
um the only thing that um that i would
like to add is
if there are further concerns of noise
coming from
in inside the property seeing that it's
open to 11 o'clock the committee could
consider
asking that all windows and doors are
closed after 9 pm also
except for ingress and egress so that
may help
if there were you know if there was
noise inside the property it would
further
insulate the property from noise thank
you
would the member of public like to sum
up
you're asking me i am yes basically yeah
sure yeah just
making sure yeah so i think i've sent it
to you i think
a further expansion of the business
has further negative impact for us and
and i would like you to to consider that
especially as i know that we're always
pushing the rules right with
retrospective applications
even right now with the with the the
compliance
right now to uh to the to the flu and
then and the
the odor so i would really like to see
if you could cut tails as much as we can
for our benefit as residents
thank you thank you uh would the
applicant like to sum up
um yeah just uh basically obviously you
know
we tried to do our best for the
neighbors including mr kramer
we have put some extra fencing at the
back
trying to do the sound barriers we we've
moved the garden further forward this
way in the back garden
so it's further away from him um and
erected other fences we've moved on in
the area
although the camps will collect the bins
um so we are constantly on it
the i know this has nothing to do with
this application but the odor the flu
isn't finished yet
um again we're having problems just
getting the extension for that
that has been discussed with the
enforcement officers so we do everything
that we've asked to do we jump through
all the hoops
we dot the eyes and we cross the t's um
we will
agree to you know closing the windows
and doors
especially at the back of the property
we have some big bi-fold doors which we
can agree to close at nine o'clock
so it doesn't and that is the closest
point to mr kramer so we you know we
will do everything we can
to try and make it easier and quieter
for mr kramer
thank you thank you very much
the members of the subcommittee will now
leave this meeting along with the
council's legal representative to
deliberate
this matter in private we shall resume
here to deliver a verdict in 30 minutes
time
whilst we leave the meeting i will ask
the democratic services officer to
explain the retiring
process thanks chad i just noticed that
um miss brooks raised her hand i don't
know if she's got something she'd like
to say sorry i didn't see that
and i just wanted to say that obviously
any time restraint you put on
this application is purely for the first
floor on the balcony
it doesn't affect anything that's
already in place for downstairs
so it's purely anything will be for the
first floor area
and the balcony the two new parts of the
application
thank you
thank you is it back to you okay thank
you very much
um so we uh the councillors myself
and the uh legal officer will go to a
private room now
and to come up with the decision
and we will then return back here using
this meeting room
um in 30 minutes so we'll say we'll meet
you back here at 11 o'clock
you can choose either to remain in the
room as you are now and just mute your
microphone turn your video off
um or you can leave and come back using
the same meeting link
as you used previously to get into this
one
so we will see you back here at 11
o'clock
welcome back it's now 11 o'clock
i would like to invite mrs phillips the
principal litigation solicitor
to read a summary of the subcommittee
determination
thank you thank you in the application
of well for the variation of the
premises license at the waves
bnb at two hengist road birchington
the phanet district council as the
relevance licensing authority in
accordance with section 12
of the licensing act and upon
consideration of representations made to
the licensing committee today
who were made which was made by the
licensing authority alison brook
the applicant steve hayden and the
member of the public
johannes kramer and also the
environmental health
officer the it is the decision of the
licensing subcommittee
that the application be granted in
considering the licensing objectives
it is the view of the committee that the
variation of the license would not
prevent crime and disorder will not
contribute to public
safety or detract from public safety
will not contribute to nuisance
and will meet the objective of
protecting children from harm
it has been noted that the member of the
public expressed concerns
as to the impact of the extension of the
business
on his premises and that
the business is on a residential road
but the applicant has agreed to close
the doors and the windows on the first
floor and this has been noted and also
the application is subject to further
scrutiny
under the planning permission
that it's waiting for and that is our
decision today
thank you
thank you and i will now adjourn this
meeting and reconvene at 11 30
in order to consider agenda item 4 the
application for a new club premises
certificate for the gold room vip
private club
thank you